[Music]
let's talk about your show notes on the
show that you are constantly like you
know it's part of a big part of your job
as a vampire to sprout teeth bite people
on the neck drink their blood and it
seems to me like it's very important to
have the correct vampire face or am I
wrong there does seem to be like there a
required face that a vampire must make
just before biting into the neck yeah
absolutely because you have to be you
have to be vicious and sort of scary and
scare the audience but then you're
drinking this fake blood which is really
actually disgusting in real life your
life what is it just sugar red sugar
mixed with blood yeah yeah look real
yeah yeah a little bit and and so you
have to sort of like look seductive and
sexy and yet at the same time scary and
me that's what I've noticed is it's a
combination of I'm terrifying but I'm
also aroused and sexual at the same time
horrible that's a sort of like you know
[Applause]
why am I doing this with you the wink
it's the wink that really puts thanks a
lot Andy okay all right but it would
help if you had teeth it would have
looked a lot better if you liked the
whole thing yeah I don't have those you
know what we did have if you could show
us we brought your vampire teeth maybe
you could give me a down stration these
are actually your vampire teeth that you
use on the show and maybe you could just
give us a demonstration Katherine's
teeth no I don't know it just said teeth
yes yes I know I just oh and by the way
while you try to look sexy these things
you would get a lisp really not quickly
at all I know real vampires would have a
lisp
I mean do you want to point it when
you're practicing you try not to you try
not to have a less than you can look is
there a cam where's your cam there's
that's my camera and you sort of have to
[Applause]
I wanna see that's right to my camera
[Applause]
you can work at it work out that's nice
right here if you need me right here to
help